I live my life in filters whenever I see
a great photo I quickly snap it pick the
best Instagram filter and post it then
and I hate to admit it i religiously
check to see how many likes I've got but
you know what that's lazy I can't just
expect to slap on a basic filter and see
the likes roll in but over the last
couple of weeks I found the secret to
getting more likes and also making my
photos look way better first add a puppy
or two puppies okay I realize that
really isn't a secret but puppies really
do equal instant likes now if you don't
have a puppy there are a whole group of
new apps that include new filters and
better photo editing tools that can
actually make your photos look like you
took them with a DSLR the popular
vscocam and a new one called lightly
make instagrams filter features look
like they're from 1977 but if you really
want better photos you got to put some
effort into it after lots of snapping I
found visco cam to be the best option
but it does require some training just
like these guys this go cam which is
available for iOS and Android isn't only
good for post-production but also taking
photos there's one setting that turns
the entire screen of the phone into a
shutter button and even a level to make
sure your shot is in crooked you can
grab photos from your camera roll too
but like many things in this app
figuring out how to do that can be
confusing and actually watched a how-to
video about using the app but visco cam
makes up for that with its awesome
editing tools sometimes all I need to do
to a photo is adjust the exposure
contrast and temperature if I want a
more stylized look though there are
these preset filters which can all be
adjusted with a slider the best part is
that they're more tasteful and toned
down than instagrams filters I guess I'm
boring you guys you don't care about
filters anyway I did buy a six dollar
pack of the disco cam filters but I
actually didn't find them any better
than the presets these guys look
perfectly cuddly on their own
then once I'm confident in my shot and
my editing I export the photo to
Instagram and wait for the likes to flow
in lightly is a new iPhone app and it's
easier to use in biscoe cam but doesn't
have as many tricks it uses the regular
iphone camera and has fewer editing
tools to that said I bought a 12 pack of
filters for two dollars through the app
and have been really liking one called
Hepburn faded like vscocam lightly lets
you see the original version of your
photo at any time during the edit by
holding two fingers on the screen it
also lets you pan to see the entire
photo I tried other apps to like aviary
and photoshop touch but didn't like any
of them as much afterlight for iOS is a
good option but i still like visco cam
the best for its editing and subtle
filters while it is a bit more
complicated to use my photos have looked
the best with it and gotten the most
lights yes it means not being so filter
lazy and some more work for you but it's
worth it you know it's also worth all
the work one of these guys